you know what i was when i was an intern
on your show i was a control room intern
and the one of the jobs in addition to
getting coffee and people always go oh
you got coffee for conan
oh i wish i got i got coffee
for jordan schlansky yes jordan
schlansky
i always keep a photo of him nearby
jordan schlansky has become
a oddly revered
a revered and reviled figure because we
started putting jordan
this is long after you were on the show
as an intern but we started putting him
on the air because we found him
so odd and strange and kind of elitist
and robotic and we started putting him
on the show
everywhere i go now everywhere i go
people say
where's jordan is jordan real so you can
tell
everybody mike you worked directly
underneath jordan as an intern he's my
main he was my boss
tell us tell people what he's really
like what i like best about jordan
what i like least about jordan is it
always seemed like he didn't like me
he does give that impression he always
but in the end on my last day he goes if
you ever need a recommendation
here's my number here i go oh i guess he
did like me i don't know i can't read
this guy
yeah i think he wanted to trap you in
some weird situation
so then i'm being honest with you when
he says give me your number
here's my number call me to an intern
you know you just
you just have to be careful that's all
you have to do so
what i like best about jordan schlansky
and i
asked if i could say this on air because
i thought this was sensitive material
is that like he'd come back from these
like
very social weekends and everyone would
go
jordan what'd you do over the weekend
and he would go like
well me and my friends would go we
we we went into the mountains and we all
got completely naked and then we sort of
jogged around for a little while
and everyone would be like what and then
he'd be like well we got completely
naked and jogged
like what like literally like the what
and him explaining it again kept
happening
over and over again for about 40 minutes
yeah what people
uh think so many people have seen the
videos i've done with him
and they think that it's an act and that
he's a character it's not
he really is that guy and i can totally
see him saying
yes the body is beautiful it is natural
and he
he talks like spock the body is a
beautiful it is natural
there's nothing sexual at all about
these encounters we just like our bodies
to be free
we like our bodies to be in nature and
so we like to move through space and
time
using our bodies and we don't want to be
encumbered by clothing
so i'm not a weird guy
not even exaggerating i mean that's
what's amazing about it and whoa the
reason why i think
i thought he didn't like me this was my
proof
is that one day they brought in someone
brought in and
handed out conan and conan o'brien
insignia
golf balls and it's a late night with
conan o'brien why i don't
i don't play golf i don't know why some
idiot made those i don't know
i don't know it was not me but i guess
someone made those yeah so they handed
them out
i hand them out i go jordan i go do you
think i could have a sleeve
of conan o'brien golf balls and he looks
at me and he goes
no what and so
and so what i so kind of what i got for
you today is a gift
and and and they can get you over there
this just uh was handed to me
just before you started uh before you
came online
i don't hold a grudge look i don't hold
a grudge
that is a
that is a mike brabiglia
golf ball now let me understand you
asked
what 15 20 years ago if you could have
a conan o'brien golf ball and you were
told by jordan schlansky
no yeah no yeah and then you do that
for you no and that's when i knew as an
unpaid intour
that's when i knew as an unpaid intern
intern
what my place was yeah he was letting
you know
that's so kind of you can i ask you a
question did you just
did you just write your name on pen on
[Laughter]
because it looks suspiciously like that
that's a limited edition set and it's uh
priceless
as far as i understand it so maybe
donate that one to charity